[Music]
let's go to hunter in michigan oh that
sounds like a
like a character like from an awesome
movie or something i'm a hunter from
michigan it's cool man what's up
not much john thanks for uh taking the
call absolutely brother how can i help
ma'am
so i've been dealing with anxiety and
depression for a while now
but it's really been spiking before work
almost every morning huh i'm waking up
with stomachaches throwing up
crying
just feel like i'm not comfortable
leaving the house yeah
so tell me about that
when you say for a while how long
so
the
back in the day i guess i always just
call them nerves and when i say back in
the day i feel like
all the way to my youth
playing sports i always used to throw up
before the games because i was just so
nervous i just said it was nerves and
then i left high school where i felt
very comfortable and moved to college
that was a community college not far
from my home
and it was the biggest change and that's
when everything hit and when i actually
had to go to a doctor and
try and figure something out
so
man
what's your journey been like with the
doctors
um
you know
once i
i was diagnosed that freshman year of
college they put me on a medication
everything kind of started to get better
i ended up finishing college
and then coveted hit
and it was last year christmas time i
hit rock bottom there you go just i was
just talking about in that last segment
about
man we all started buzzing right
huh yep
man so how old are you now
i just turned 24.
so if you could paint a picture of what
you want your life to look like
give me some descriptions of that what
would that look like
i just um i want to find a job that i
enjoy that i
that it's not
40 hours of my week
52 weeks a year just waiting for a
paycheck
i want to be secure i want to be with my
family i want to have time
man i hear it in you man and i want to
tell you i'm grateful for your bravery
it's hard to say that stuff out loud and
i'm grateful for you
so i've been there right where you're at
and so i want to start this whole
conversation by saying
i take no medication
not that that's bad i'm just telling you
there's
a there's a
light at the end of the tunnel
for me and it didn't involve medication
it does involve
a lot of laughter
and a lot of joy
and seasons when i run low
and i've come to accept that i don't
fight him anymore
and times when my body tries to get my
attention and i listen now i don't try
to ignore
and really it's been about charting my
own path over the last 10 15 years
so i want you to know there's healing on
the other side of this thing do you
believe me
i do yeah because i have hip like i said
rock bottom and then i feel
better you know i i felt fine again it's
just you know what's
what's going on i'm not i'm not stressed
at work there's nothing really stressing
me out my job's not stressful um i think
it's just going to work yeah um i i
might on average
say
three or four sentences a day like good
morning
good night
that's really it so all day you heard me
you may have heard me in the last
segment the
one of
one of the things things anxiety is an
alarm system right that just lets us
know that we're not safe and that we're
not connected or we are not in a
situation where we have any control
so i've said it a thousand times over
the last two years we should have some
anxiety going on
when we're just not allowed to work
because our mere presence can kill
somebody right
right um or when we think that we're
being lied to or cheat whatever the
thing happens to be you know
um so
some of that anxiousness is normal it's
our body trying to get our attention
being like whoa we don't have any
control here guys and so
i've made peace with that
i appreciate my body trying to get to
keep me safe and get my attention
the two things you've mentioned one is
community college leaving high school
and going to community college and then
the other is
getting dropped into a job where you say
five or six sentences a day
where is your human interaction your
human connection these days
where's your friends
working
they work you know same
same thing i do monday through friday
and then i go home and i'm with my
fiance and
i mean that's the interaction i get
pretty much during the day you know i go
home and see her
might see some of my family members they
all live pretty close but if i see my
friends most likely on the weekend
so the first thing i want you to do is
to make that
numero uno priority
i'm told i mean you and i are talking
for three minutes on the radio right so
i'm spitballing here
right but my hunch tells me that your
body senses it has lost its tribe
and if you can imagine 10 000 years ago
you woke up on the plains of
southern michigan and your tribe had
left you
you were probably gonna die and your
body would sound every alarm it had to
reconnect with other people get up now
run now
and find your tribe
and your body's telling you you're not
safe because you don't have anybody
um
can i ask you a hard question
yeah absolutely shoot
so when i was really crippled with this
with anxiety
i liked the feeling of alertness
i liked the feeling of always being in
the know of being ahead of the crowd if
you will
and over time i got chemically addicted
to that feeling of always buzzing
my body associated
rest with not being on guard so rest
wasn't a safe place for me rest was a
distressing place for me
do you
are you addicted to feeling anxious
i might be honestly because i go to bed
thinking about what's going to happen
the next morning it's almost like i know
it's going to happen so
let's just feel like
let's park there for a second what is
your body protecting you from at work
i'm not sure is there a chance you can
get fired
no are you do you hate your job
no i don't hate it
do you hate what you're doing
um
yeah does your dad tell you you should
be doing something else or making more
money
no
nobody's really forcing me to do
anything or saying that i should change
just
you know
things come along when they should come
along
you don't believe that though
no i've always been
make it out yeah yes make it happen yeah
i
you know i paint a picture and i'm gonna
make that picture happen i love it
hunter but why aren't you doing that in
this case
scared i guess of what
not being secure
not having a job
so right now you're trading security for
anxiety is it worth it
probably not no it's killing you
and by the way i painted you a false
binary picture there
i'm very secure in my job
and i'm not anxious anymore by the way
it's not at both i've had jobs where
i've not been anxious okay um working
with my friends you know growing up
through high school i worked with them
building fences and that was
a lot of fun but you had
community yes yeah andy let me let me
push on you you had someone to talk to
and right now for whatever reason you're
choosing not to talk
and that the demon of anxiety is it
spins you tighter and tighter to where
you feel like you're the only one
experiencing this thing and the way you
got to navigate the world is either
spewing on everybody or saying nothing
to anybody do you vomit on your wife
i mean on your fiancee does she get a
big chunk of this
no
like she yeah she handles a brunt of it
i try not to because
we get married in a couple weeks and she
takes her state boards actually today as
we
speak and so here's what happens you're
hurting and you don't want to hurt her
with your hurt so you hold it back
and she feels a gap between the two of
you
which pushes her closer to you or
further away and that further signals
your anxiety alarms you see how this
thing just spins and spins and spins and
spins
spirals out of control that's right
so let me ask you this directly do you
want to be free
yeah
do you want to just lay down at night
and fall asleep
yeah my sleep latency now is less than
one minute you know what that means
that when my head hits the pillow i'm
out
can you imagine that
yeah
it's like a i remember when i was in the
throes of a dude it was like a fantastic
i didn't believe anybody had that
yeah
now my wife makes fun of me on friday
nights when we have family movie night
or something she's like it's family
movie night and john knapp night
because i do i sleep anywhere now it's
incredible
yeah do you want that
i do okay and i think i think a lot of
it john stems from the job because i've
always said
people of i'm in school that you're
always taught what are you passionate
about what do you love to do try and
find a job to make money that way well i
loved
money and that's what kind of drew me to
the ramsey podcast and you and how i
even know about this show but
i
i feel like i don't know what i'm
passionate about or how to get
a job
like that too so make myself happier so
i want you to hang on the line i'm going
to get you two things i'm going to be my
gift to you i'm going to give you my
friend ken coleman's book from paycheck
to purpose and i'm going to give you his
career assessment too okay
that would be amazing and uh my friend
pat lincione do you know that name
i do not he's
the
one the greatest
executive coaches on planet earth he
runs an extraordinary consulting group
one of the most highly respected men in
the industry
um he has a working genius
instrument that you can get for 25 off
if you put in go to patentyoni.comy
and it's like 10 bucks or 18 bucks or
something like that i want you to do
that too
okay i can do that yeah
and
so those are a couple things i'm just
going to give you out of the gate do you
have a pin
um i do okay so i want you to write this
stuff down
this is 30 days
number one do not stop taking your
medication are you still on now
yep okay good number two
no caffeine cut it out
yep okay are you already there
yeah so you don't you don't have any
caffeine in your life
no oh sweet cut your sugar way down you
already there
should do better
not me dude i'm perfect just kidding i
just snort sugar off the counter with a
strawberry
all right what is your trigger besides
work
when i'm not in
control what does that feel like
i
panicked
like i don't know what's going to happen
or when i don't know what's coming up
next because again i'm not in control
describe your body feeling to me
uh
stomach aches overwhelmed yeah you get
that warm feeling in your stomach it
drops yeah oh yeah and then your your
chest tightens way up
when that happens i want you to have a
note card with you that you keep at all
times okay
and i want you to stop
and write down you may have to pull over
for 30 days okay
this is that important don't wait until
you get somewhere stop if you're walking
if you're at work you're in the middle
of a phone call say hey let me let me uh
put you on hold and i'll call you right
back
and i want you to write down right then
what am i not in control of
whatever it is
like you just thought about the weather
and you're like oh my gosh it could be
snowing and then ice and then i'm not
gonna be looking at my driveway and then
uh and that your body takes over i want
you to stop pull out that note card and
say i cannot control the weather
i will be safe driving home period
and here's what we're doing when your
body goes limbic when it sets off the
anxiety alarms it literally disconnects
part of your frontal lobe and again i'm
i'm i'm making this as easy as possible
it trades
safety i mean it trades speed for
accuracy it just starts spinning out all
these different and what you're doing
when you pull out this note card is you
are bringing your thinking brain back
online
okay
and here this is a magic word write this
down in circle and put stars by it
you're gonna practice
you're just teaching your body a new way
to respond
okay
i got so anxious of the anxiety coming
and then i stopped doing things that
might be fun or exciting or a little bit
nerve-racking because i got scared of
the anxiousness
okay
i want you to begin to lean into those
things and just note when your body
takes off on you and then here's a magic
sentence to say
oh man
thank you for trying to take care of me
i'm good
you're right i can't control the stock
market or inflation i can't
i can't
and it will still do its thing for a
season
and in my experience over after working
with tons of p over time your body
begins to go oh he's in control of this
thing
okay
i want you to be militant about a sleep
routine
that means two hours before you go to
bed turn all the screens off for an hour
before you go to turn all screens off
read fiction not drama books or not
science books okay go to the library and
get some just
cheesy fiction
okay okay
i want you to give your brain a break in
the evenings
and then this is the big one
four times a day
do you live with your fiance i do
four times a day skin on skin contact
not sexual doesn't have to be sexual
four times a day right when you wake up
right before you go to work right when
you get home before you go to bed
skin on skin contact 10 to 30 seconds
okay
hold hands touch feet
whatever it is and i want you to slowly
begin to
drop your shoulders when you do it
that's it okay okay
and last one call some friends
say starting this monday every monday
night we're getting together and then
you know what they may tell you to screw
off let me say i'm not doing it don't
have time too busy whatever
that's a risk that you got to take and i
want you to keep going and keep going
you have to have a tribe not your fiance
not your family you got to get a gang
okay not a gang of weirdos there in
michigan either by the way right join
some crazy lunatic group that wants to
don't do that
it won't good but
do find a group of guys you can go play
cards with or go bowling with or go to
arcade with or go serve the poor with do
something okay
is that fair
that's fair
you still see a counselor
i do okay
have you ever said the words
i'm ready to stop
being anxious
um
i mean i've i feel like i've said yeah i
want this to end there you go yeah
there's no reason to stop there you go
so
when you say i want this to end i want
to feel better i want to not be anxious
anymore
our language is saying this is a thing
that's happening to us
when i take ownership and i say
i'm ready to stop being so anxious all
the time
now i'm gonna do things about my
thoughts
i'm gonna begin to change my thoughts
i'm gonna do things about my actions i'm
gonna change my actions and i'm gonna
live into a life
it is intentionally less anxious and i'm
gonna have to learn a new way of living
because i'm not gonna be electrified all
the time and let me tell you
your body needs to be on guard because
you're not in control and i gotta
control gotta control gotta control
dude i'm telling you on the other side
of that the peace from not trying to
control everything is unbelievable
it's unbelievable
and this is the pot talking to the
kettle give yourself the opportunity to
live a life of peace
all right your body can spin itself up
when it needs to and get a new job i
don't mean i don't say that flippantly
you got to find a place to work right
you know that
yeah you do you know so i'm gonna hook
you up with ken coleman stuff and with
pat lucione stuff i want you to check
out where you want to be where you need
to be and then ken's book walks you
through the steps on how to get there i
want you to go make it happen cool thank
you yeah thank you very much brother
there is peace and healing on the other
end of this
there's a light at the end of that
tunnel my man there is